dr. Kareem abu zaid specialists and
prefers to be called student knowledge
by your specialists in this field you
actually had and you were for several
years and answering many of these
questions on let's talk about it yeah we
used to have a shul yeah
so you're someone who specializes in
answering these type of questions
nowadays I don't know if you're familiar
and with the Ultimate Fighting
Championships some of these sports that
are out there combat or people
it's called mixed martial arts where you
have you got the boxing kickboxing and
wrestling all this together now there is
a a for a more elaborate response we
have one of your colleagues I believe
dr. hot Tim yeah yeah a judge a judge
and then go to the Dean show calm where
he talks about boxing hitting in the
face and and this and the the what is
Islam Stan just in a nutshell this is
something that would be if someone asks
you if they can get involved in a sport
like this the I don't know he has he he
has a whole detailed you know response
they can go to that but let's assume not
to put you on the spot someone's already
in it they're already in it's okay so
you're not authorizing that someone can
do it but someone is already in it
they're Muslim they're already in it
you're not gonna get them out okay so
you're not gonna and then some people
out the way like the the the lesser of
two evils right let's say someone was
you had actually had an imam son right
he couldn't get him off the street you
know what I mean and this is the only
way to save him right right to save this
kid so he got involved in these sports
my point what I'm trying to say and
again for a lab or as someone gets into
into this they can go and they can see
your colleague it's on the Dean show
kinda just put boxing or something but
now someone has the spotlight and we're
talking about Dawa when somebody is up
in that area and millions of people are
shining on them watching them what
responsibilities now you're there you
log okay you want it Allah gave you a
chance to go ahead what are you going to
do with it now
what responsibility should a Muslim have
he's a Muslim you know what I mean to go
ahead and use this platform for Dawa
what do you think I really don't know
what brother had him said you know it's
not allowed he's it's not yeah about it
but he said it's not basically it's not
allowed yeah I don't know what you I'm
gonna speak your language yes you know
that sure that you would for people
uh-huh how will it sound if you stand in
front of this world who brace do so much
yeah and say I'm sorry I have to retire
because my religion this allows me to do
this
imagine this message that you give you
know again it's that message of Muslims
being barbarian you know and imagine why
not do that and you know when Turkish al
dila
if you leave something for the sake of
Allah a waterhole La Jolla element Allah
will replace it with something much
better for you no compromise in this
because we you have a crystal clear text
about it punching in the face and the
the aggressiveness of this is proper
English
you know the aggression and mmm so no
okay so we got that out of the way
that's that would it's better to even if
you're in it to retire from it because
yeah this is something that would not be
permitted based on what you said the
hadith he mentions reciprocating the
harm this yeah and there's a bunch of
again for more elaborate academic you
know answer a you can go to the Dean
show and watch it but now until the
person this is a great thing okay than
what you just said but now I see a lot
of while a person is there maybe they're
not there yet to do that right what
advice do you give them until they do
that right instead of you know citing
article people signing autographs
little things that I see that people can
do like where they can go ahead and send
a nice message you know because what do
you know what I you know I'll give you
an example when someone comes to take a
picture with me see why I can either be
rude and you know or not want to take a
picture and then people are gonna be
think I'm stuck up arrogant but I say I
take a a message out purpose of life
every one day so now there's Dow in the
pictures in the autograph someone asks
you right and you put always remember
God always remember Allah you follow me
Muhammad Ali what he used to do was he
used to have brochures his Jesus guy and
he would sign those and give them out
right so little things like that that
people can do to share while they're
doing is what is your advice on that
nobody you get what I'm saying because
there's a lot of maybes a lot of these
fun a lot of these people out there
exactly and again you're going in
circles and I will gonna bring you back
to the center of the circle yeah it's
laughs you know you know have you ever
been in would I fly a lot so that's why
you ever heard the the flight attendant
making that announcement that in case of
emergency something's gonna drop from
you know for the blood water for the
yeah the oxygen make sure you help
yourself first even if you have a child
sitting next to you yes don't help that
child help yourself first listen I am in
the business of saving myself and
hopefully my family yes that's my
priority now I'm not gonna become a
bridge where people go to paradise
go to guidance and then at the end I
will be thrown into hell don't do that
yeah don't burn yourself and order
follow your religion first the religion
bans you from doing this submit to Allah
give up this for the sake of Allah and
if Allah wills he will use you in other
venues and other means to propagate and
promote Islam but don't burn yourself in
order to save others nobody said that
leave it at that